Before you get started with
this nano degree program,
it's really important for you to
evaluate whether or not you're ready for
the kinds of things we're
going to talk about.
We're try and build as much knowledge
necessary for machine learning into
the curriculum, but there's some things
you need to know before you get started.
If you aren't familiar
with any of these things,
we invite you to use some of
the resources that we've provided, or
some of the resources available online
to learn the requisite knowledge to
get started.
Generally speaking, what you really need
to know to get started is some math.
You need to know some basic statistics,
some basic calculus, and
some basic linear algebra.
If you can do these like calculating
a standard deviation by hand,
calculating a derivative, or
calculating a determinate of a matrix,
then you're probably ready
to get started here.
Now, of course, at some point
during the nano degree program you
might come across something
that you're not familiar with.
And in that case, we invite you to
pause, go look up some additional
information and learn what you
need to know to move forward.